[Music]
so to make the vlog more interesting Liv
and I are taking a day away from Exeter
which is any down briefly so we are
making the most of the Sun today and
going to the beach but we're getting the
bus there and one of my favorite things
about this country is well other names
and Devon is blessed with some of the
best names you'll ever see like for
example we could go to 0 mana quorum
next to charity and fit Spain can we go
to shilling foots and Jorge or perhaps
we could go to Dada's connelly
daughter's comely goddess daddies come
play dollars come sleigh
[Music]
oh really
we made it simpler the beach is just a
little bit busy then so we don't have
much of a plan per se what we're gonna
do today basically lives down for a
brief period of time the weather was
nice and she really wants to get in the
sea so that's kind of the plan we just
had to look around the parish church
here which is quite cute and gonna get
lunch this is a very boring like day to
watch on the vlog but it's still the
most interesting day this week for you
guys oh I assumed it was their age ah
right that makes more sense
are we old is what old people do Beach
so Fleming at the beach is kind of
difficult because you don't look like a
pedophile and I also can't share pics
ago and I don't want to show you my body
because I'm feeling fat but rest assured
we doesn't predict in the sea and it was
very picturesque because the coast here
is amazing you might actually recognize
this bit of coast what it's worth we
might drown the last time we were in
Fiddler in a winter pebble beaches
though not the one when it comes to
comfort so pick so go what can you give
me the top three reasons why people
should come to Sigma that's a very good
description and no crab very importantly
no crabs so live and I are amazed at
these rocks they've been balanced really
carefully but there are children and
dogs everywhere so it's kind of a
miracle they've just couldn't left
undisturbed or as the points out they
they might just be good we're passable
hopefully this video is gonna do a bit
more good for the tourism and Sigma the
last video did but it's definitely
submitted like a Greek dreary place it's
actually really nice when it's sunny
[Music]
I'm out of ice cream yeah do I look no
go on
no really pixelated no I'm gonna pick
say my tongue yeah
[Music]
so kind of one hand
it turns out that we don't have money
for ice cream we thought we had more so
I've been holding these two for house
five minutes livers going to get money
and apparently the nearest cash point
doesn't work so this is gonna be very
messy okay okay live made it back just
about makes it as days off goes yep as
days up go this one's all right yeah
that's staying in now okay thank you
thank you pixel girl this is the problem
any day at languages
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay so it's currently much later in the
day basically we got back here and
chilled we had dinner we started
watching crazy-ass girlfriend on Netflix
which has become I think one of our new
favorites so that's pretty cool and the
day and week or at a close this is very
heads down working week and I'm sorry if
it's made for a boring vlog I'm sure
I've tried to make it as interesting as
I can with editing but you know the day
my life at the moment is me working
eleven twelve hours a day so it's only
so much I can do we are closing it now
though we're closing in on the great
battle of our time between me and my
thesis at the moment I feel like
everything's kind of falling into place
like the trajectory is up yes it's just
putting in the work until you go into
Teague finish and in a way it's it's a
way if this has been one of the best
times the PhD because so long it's felt
like I've just been pushing against an
immovable object and there's so many
years pushing and pushing and pushing
and trying until you know you sweat and
you bleed don't you want to cry and
finally with a position where you pull
that effort you know actually moves it
budges and it's like I've just got to
keep pushing keep moving this thing and
it's like you want to push it off a
cliff or up to the top of a ramp or
something and it's like no it's moving
and it's awful it's horrible when you're
doing it but you just gotta keep going
and eventually you'll get there that's
kind of where I'm at the moment I have
the vast majority of a complete thesis
in terms of pages done and hopefully cuz
I'm not gonna blog next week hopefully
the next week have a log which will
probably be the week after that or maybe
the week after that
hopefully you'll be witness to me
finally finishing this bloody thing off
in the meantime though thank you for
watching I hope this video wasn't too
boring and I will see in the next vlog
you can do this
[Music]